honey mama what is it I have to go with
Roy I was told to take a man to hotel I
said that he was an enemy of the state
take off your dress
and in exchange my mother look at the
doctor she made him instead they cut his
throat
there could be no witnesses
so they gave me a choice die or become a
sparrow from this day forward you will
become space-weapons in a global
struggle for power you'll be trained to
be psychological manipulation you must
learn to push yourself beyond all
limitation take off your clothes when we
are finished with you the person you
were will no longer exist every human
being is a puzzle of need you must
become the missing piece and they will
tell you anything you have a gift you
know how to survive this is what you
want
is a traitor in the government as last
no contact is an American did close I'm
a very simple yesterday are we going to
become friends tell what you want just
Sparrow the only matter cause of what
you can do for them work with me and
make these men hey you are better this
than any of us your only problem is you
have a soul
we can't trust a word that comes out of
her mouth
there's something else or in LCM she's
compromised she will be eliminated what
have you done
you belong to them they won't ever let
go I'll find a way
[Music]